how do you describe what you do for work
when you meet somebody yeah this is
something which frequently comes up and
it's really tricky to explain because I
think the the most common thing I say is
have you seen the movie 21 because if
they've seen that movie they already
have a basic understanding of at least
the theatrical version of what card
counting is and if they haven't seen
that movie I just ask them if they know
what card counting is and a lot of the
time people don't know and then I'm in a
really tricky spot because when you try
and describe professional gambling you
do sound a bit
saying right yeah I keep track of the
cards at casinos and have a complex
system of friends who have money
bankrolled by Anonymous huge donors and
we try and we try and rip casinos off
yeah essentially yeah it does sound like
a criminal enterpr Enterprise when you
put it like that but yeah actually you
put it really well actually just keeping
track of the cards is quite an accurate
way of doing it because most people
think that you're memorizing all of the
cars you see which is way harder than
what we're actually doing even though
what we're doing is relatively cool so
keeping track is like a nice way of of
summarizing it because we're actually
assigning each card in the deck with a
different point point value separate to
its points in the game of blackjack and
then we're keeping track of that running
total which we're using to get an
advantage over the house basically dude
I love your YouTube I think your Vlogs
that you're doing with hidden cameras as
you go in and take these casinos for
everything they're worth until you get
found out and rumbled and then escorted
off the premises I I absolutely love
them I think they're fantastic so
everybody should go and check out check
out your Vlogs once they finish uh
listening to this but talk to me about
how somebody begins their apprenticeship
into the world of professional Casino
Ripper
offerer yeah yeah yeah so card counting
falls under the bracket of Advantage
play and an advantage player essentially
anybody that can beat a casino game in
this case legally so there's a
difference between card counting and
Advantage play and cheating so cheating
would be you know you're sneaking an
extra card in or you're maybe using
technology where it's illegal to use
software to run a computer algorithm to
crunch numbers to beat the game so with
Advantage play you're just playing the
game within the rules with the same
information that everybody else has in
the casino in theory you're just using
it in a different way so if you want to
get into card counting it's it's firstly
something that I really don't recommend
for most people because the actual
lifestyle of it can be quite brutal and
the way that I have it is I play for a
bit and then I have that quite a large
break and I think the time I was most
stressed in my life when I was playing 6
hours a day essentially like a n well
not quite a 9-to-5 but I was treating it
like a 9o5 job playing six days a week
and even though you're playing with an
advantage you can just lose so much
money and even though you know you're
going to win in the long term the
psychological impact of losing the money
is really really strong but essentially
if someone wants to learn how to to card
count there's books there's resources
there's online websites now and you just
go through it like you would any other
skill I don't think it's particularly
way harder than the average skill it's
just that with card counting you have
very very little margin for error so you
have to master each element of card
counting and get it perfect otherwise
you'll just lose loads of money because
your Edge is reliant on your mind being
completely correct and when the margin
Edge that you have is only slightly
above
50% any mess up by the brain drags that
back for sure yeah which is why also we
need like tons of money to even do it
because we're playing with such a small
Edge you can still have a losing streak
that could go on you know one of my
teammates had a 300H hour losing streak
and it's just insane so if you don't
have loads of money to bet the amounts
that we're betting which is you know in
the thousands per hand well the low
thousands like you know a k k and a half
if you don't have 100 200 300
$400,000 then you could just burn
through all that on a bad run so there's
a lot of stuff that needs to be taken
into consideration that's one of the
biggest mistakes that a lot of new card
counters will make they will Master how
to count cards but then when it comes to
the actual bankroll management and the
risk management of it they won't pay any
attention to that they'll blow through
their bank roll in a very short amount
of time and then they'll be that'll be
it they'll be bankrupt from card
counting so you gotta be super careful
who is it not specifically but where is
it that you're finding half a mill to
fund a trip to go and travel around the
US yeah so the way that I actually
started was incredibly reckless in that
you know I collaborated with a another
YouTuber who he's a card counter and he
teaches people to to card count called
Colin Jones and I got in touch with him
mainly because I thought this would make
a really firstly it was just like a
bucket list item I thought I really want
to do this and I also had a a small
YouTube channel doing magic tricks and I
thought this would make a really cool
Vlog Series so I got in touch with him
and I thought maybe he'll bankroll me
you know 10K or something or maybe I I
didn't really have any money at the time
so I wasn't sure how I was going to sort
the money thing out at the time but then
one day I was moving house and I had a
friend that was just helping me move
house and I was telling him what I was
getting up to and I was going to go to
America for a month and count cards and
then he just shot me a message later on
going hey can I invest in you and I was
like sure and I think he offered to put
something like 10 to 15K in I can't
quite remember the exact number off the
top of my head but then as we kept
chatting he just up that and eventually
just said that he'd put 200k in in
pounds so more than that in
USD and that's the money that I played
with now at the time I misunderstood how
the risk of card counting like the
actual numbers on cang how long it takes
you to get to guaranteed profit so I
didn't realize how risky this was and
it's extra bad because he was actually
he actually gave me his mortgage so I
was playing with money that he couldn't
afford to lose which is insane by all
accounts and goes against what every
professional Gambler would say all
professional gamblers would be like
you've got to have your bank roll that's
separate if you lose that you've got to
be okay but we were essentially all in
and it would have probably ruined his
life if I'd lost all of of that money
and also the crushing guilt I would have
felt so I don't really know why you get
200 Grand to count cards have a friend
that has a mortgage and then he gives
you the money but a reckless a reckless
friend yeah but nowadays as you network
with card counters card counters tend to
have money and because it's like a
profitable thing to do and then you meet
other people that want to invest in card
counters and you build out your network
that way and now it's relatively
straightforward if we're going to do a
trip we can just send a couple of texts
and WhatsApp and then raise three 400k
whatever it is that we need and they
take a cut of some kind yeah essentially
so the way that we do it different teams
do it differently and the percentage
splits are are different but the way
that we do it is we have it's it's kind
of like you're forming a company just
for one project then you dissolve it at
the end so you've got the winnings at
the end and you'll divide those 50% will
go to the investors and 50% will go to
the players and normally with the
players you you'll pay them out based
off playing time not based off how much
they've actually won because the only
thing that's within the card CS control
is showing up and Counting CS whether or
not they actually win provided their
game is good which we test ahead of time
is not up to them so we could have a
card counter that's put in loads of
hours and got the most hours but they
actually made a loss whereas we can have
someone that played the least hours and
they made a profit but we don't judge it
based off results we judge it based off
time that goes in so we split it
proportionately like that sometimes
you'll have a manager and they'll take a
manager cut because it's quite a
complicated logistical thing to manage
so you know manager might take 10% or
something but then the rest of it
usually split 50-50 with the investors
and the players talk me through a
typical team people that have seen 21
you've got a variety of people but like
probably not a previous bank robber I
can't remember the movie but what what's
what's the typical Avengers assembled
that you take on these trips well the
the actual the makeup of the team as in
the people is a complete mixed bag of
people there's maybe some card counter
stereotypes like being white and being
in your 20s is a little bit more common
but in general our team team is quite is
quite a a wide range of people we've got
like a core team and an extended team
and it's not always the exact same
people playing on a trip but the ways
that the actual team forms for a trip is
that you have two main approaches either
what we would call solo team play which
is where all the C counters are playing
individually at individual casinos in
different parts of America or where
wherever else it's going to be but
they're all sharing a bank role and that
can be really useful because it's one of
those things where the What's The Phrase
the sum is the is greater than the sum
of the parts that kind of thing because
if you had one card counter with $10,000
and another another card counter with
$11,000 and they were both playing they
can play with a certain level of bets
and they can make a certain hourly rate
on average but if you put those together
and combine the resources it's not the
equivalent of that 20K divided by two
it's actually like one card counter with
twice the money playing twice as fast so
it's really advantageous for card
counters to team up and work together
because it just it gets you to the the
mathematical long run quicker you can
have you can place bigger bets you can
win more money in theory and that's kind
of how that works so that's solo team
play the other type of team play which
is like the movie 21 and the version
that I find the most fun there are very
few card counting teams that do this is
what we' call Big player spotter team
play so one of the things which makes
card counters get caught is that we have
to bet we we're set we're set there
playing bjack like everyone else and
there's only certain moments where we
have the adant AG over the house that's
when the count is high so sometimes if
I'm playing in Vegas or wherever I might
be betting $25 a hand and then the count
goes up and I'll bet a grand a hand and
that's a huge jump and any surveillance
person that's paying attention to that
will know that most people if they're
playing Blackjack and have that kind of
money aren't betting $25 sometimes and a
grand other times they they might vary
their bets a bit a bit but never that
much so that can be a huge red flag and
we can get caught that way so with team
play what we do is we'll have different
different spotters so card counters that
are sat at different tables just betting
the table minimum they'll be keeping the
count and when the count gets high
they'll do it a secret signal to get the
attention of the big player who is also
a car counter and his or her job is just
to bet really big so let's say I signal
them in I won't be as you know it'll be
less it'll be more subtle than just
waving but if I'm just come over here
they'll come over I will either tell
them what the count is via a code word
or I will just use more signals to tell
them what to do how much to bet and how
to play hands and they'll just come over
to the table Midway through the shoe and
start betting big but they'll leave when
the count drops because I'll tell them
to go so it's really cool because
everybody's consistent all of the
spotters are playing the minimum or
close to the minimum and the big player
is only ever betting a grand of hand
roughly whatever it's going to be which
makes it more difficult for surveillance
to catch the actual big player in the
team saying that nowadays because the
movies up 21 and that system becoming
more popular pop who knows if it really
gets you more time but it's definitely
more fun yes so what you're trying to
avoid is any one player changing the
amount that they bet so the variant that
they bet shouldn't be much more okay so
going back to the solo team play or solo
play
generally how do you how do you increase
your bet when the deck is
hot when you're on your own we just do
it you just have to do it and Sort of
hope it's it's kind of a weird thing
because surveillance aren't only looking
for card counters they've got a heck of
a lot to do they're checking to make
sure that dealers don't make payout
mistakes which at you know high limit
room could cost a casino a lot of money
they're checking to make sure that
people aren't trying to steal that that
drunk guy that's walking around isn't
about to punch someone or grab some
chips from the tray surveillance have
got a really hard job and they're
actually some of the most under appre no
definitely the most underappreciated
Casino staff that exists like they get a
really raw deal in general as a whole of
the chat so the main thing is that
surveillance have got other things to do
so they're not always watching me play
Blackjack so they'd have to see me watch
me see me change my bet and only then if
I do that a few times maybe they'd start
drawing a pattern maybe they'd decide
they have to run my game down but in
general the way that I play and this
isn't how all card counters play but the
way that I play is pretty aggressively
so I'll try and bet as little as I can
when the count is low and as much as I
can when the count is high because that
maximizes the amount of money that I
have the potential to win per hour
and it's those little the bets that
you're betting when when you don't have
the advantage that cost you quite a lot
over time so we just go for it and now
I've spoken to quite a few surveillance
people just because they've reached out
to me which has been really useful and I
think that in general a relatively
aggressive approach doesn't really lose
you much more time than playing really
conservatively and trying to do all this
what we call cover play where you might
make a a little mistake with your play
so that you don't look like you you know
what you're doing these things I don't
know if they help more than they harm in
terms of your actual hourly you know
expected value the money that you earn
when you're doing the big player team
stuff each different person must have a
not necessarily a cover story but
they're projecting a particular type of
person when they go in there so what's
what sort of a person are you and then
what's your ideal big player
Persona yeah our big player is an
absolute Legend but I'll get to him in a
second yeah so for me when I'm a SP
actually I'm more concerned with just
not drawing any attention to myself
especially given that having the YouTube
channel makes me I can get recognizing
casinos so I try and just keep a
relatively low profile when I'm spotting
because I don't want to be the weak link
that gets the team busted but in general
when I'm when I'm a spotter I'll just
sit there quietly and bet the minimum
and try not to really draw any attention
to myself which is very different to how
I'll play when I'm not a spotter when
I'm doing solo play like we were just
playing in Vegas and I was playing
various different characters with
different elaborate disguises and I
would really lean into being an
extrovert or being super obnoxious we've
done all sorts of weird stuff we did a
stag to so a what's the
American bachelor party where we were
all wearing t-shirts the same and acting
acting drunk and just going around and
being incredibly loud and signaling over
the BP in those cases was literally hey
come here it was a tot different
strategy so sometimes it's a case of
standing out to blend in but our our big
player we we've played with a couple
different big players and they all have
a different style and there's not really
a right way but I think one of the
elements is just them looking
comfortable with that amount of money if
someone's new as a big player or new to
card counting then just betting you
know, do a hand or a couple k a hand can
be really daunting but our big player
that we most commonly use is called
Irish AP that's what he goes by and he
just plays this very loud
obnoxious I don't extrovert but kind of
aggressive Ang R Gambler so whenever
he's losing he's kicking up such a fuss
and just being like just cursing
constantly and just complaining about
the cards he's been dealt not really
taking it out at people but taking it
out at cards so he just plays this role
where he's so annoyed that people are a
little bit scared of him which I think
in a way can bias more time because
they're not looking at him through the
lens of a card count that's trying to
blend in they're looking at him like oh
this angry Gambler that we kind of want
to stay away from right obvious question
what's the legality of all this yeah
it's totally legal in general I mean we
could get into real specifics team play
technically could be deemed maybe
illegal in certain state in certain
States perhaps but there's a lot of
arries on that just because I don't want
to speak too definitely but in general
card counting is fine because you're
just using the same information that
anybody else has the way that I describe
it is can you imagine that you're
playing high level chess and you're like
one of the best chess players in the
world and the tournament manager comes
over Taps you on the shoulder and goes
excuse me we actually have seen well we
can tell that you're thinking four moves
ahead and in this tournament three moves
ahead is the max it's just deemed not
fair it would just be ludicrous all
we're doing is using our brains the same
way that anyone else could we're not
yeah we're not cheating it doesn't
legally classify as cheating and
therefore it's legal everywhere as far
as I'm aware the only sort of not
exactly exceptions but there certain
countries like the UK is actually weird
to count cards in because you don't have
a lot of Le legal recourse if you get
kicked out they can potentially just
withhold the money and there's been
stories from other Advantage players
like Phil Ivy did this whole thing with
uh it wasn't Blackjack that he was
playing but he did this Advantage play
it went to court he didn't get paid out
if I remember that correctly so there's
some weird stuff where there was a
person in I can't remember if it was
Ireland or Northern Ireland that played
roulette and then didn't get paid out
they weren't even they weren't cheating
or doing Advantage play they just were
playing roulette won a load of money and
then it was deemed that they were a uh
oh it's a private business so they can
do what they want so there's certain
places where you might have more
difficulties than others but legally
speaking it's not cheating and it's
perfectly legal right
so this this to me kind of Jades my not
as if I thought casinos were bastions of
ethical s High flute in Tru isness but
what I did think was if somebody does
manage to be the house that they've done
it fairly and if it's not legal the
casino should take it on the chin given
that they're fleecing every other non
Advantage player in there yeah it's it's
absolutely wild because really we don't
even Dent their bottom line and most of
the time they know that I think they
just have a a vendetta against card
counters because we actually
don't the way that we get treated
sometimes you know I've had police
called on me multiple security guards
just intimidation tactics or them
refusing to cash you out unless you show
ID which is not a legal requirement all
these kind of weird things that they'll
do for what essentially won't Dent the
average casino's bottom line it's so
rare that we'd make any kind of impact
especially like these big casinos in
Vegas it's so funny that the lengths
that they'll go to to stop you counting
when it just sometimes they will they
will ruin a blackjack game to make sure
so that it's not countable and it's just
why are you doing how would they ruin it
well there's certain things that they
can do for example if you've played a
regular shoe game of blackj where you've
got maybe six six stacks of cards
shuffled together they'll have a cut
card that goes towards the end so when
you hit that cut card they know oh yeah
we got a shuffle now but if you move
that cut card further forward that means
that you might only play say three of
the decks before a shuffle or two of the
decks if you're going to be absolutely
wild but the further forward that gets
the the Le the fewer cards or less cards
that you're going to play before Shuffle
Now the less cards you're going to play
that's bad for a card counter because
our information gets more useful more
accurate towards the end so they'll
sometimes put the cut card more forward
so that it stops card counters but the
cost of that is actually they're losing
a lot of time in rounds per hour that
other non-card counters would be playing
and people have crunched the numbers and
even just moving it a couple cards
forward costs like the average Casino a
ridiculous amount of money per year so
they'll do all sorts of things I just
describe it as they drop a nuclear bomb
on a house to blow out a candle like
yeah they'll stop card counters but they
will cause themselves so much damage in
the process so do you see the process of
this largely just being a race against
the clock to be discovered to be rumbled
what would you say is the percentage
time that you actually manage to get in
do the thing and get out having not been
recognized or noticed and how many times
do you get in there and get kicked out I
think most of the time it ends with
being kicked out well that's kind of the
goal in a way not that we want to be
kicked out but there's a there's a
phrase in card counting called Don't
Back yourself off from a casino back off
being just the term for being asked not
to play Black Jack and if I leave a
casino because I think they might kick
me out soon
then what what's that achieved I've left
I might as well have stayed and played
another hour before they'd actually
kicked me out so I I normally will play
until a back off on the trip I just did
you know in Vegas I was trying short
sessions and going from casino to casino
trying to leave before a back off but
then as soon as I compared my my hours
played with another teammate who was
just playing until back off he got way
more time and sometimes we'll feel what
we call heat which is just suspicion we
can tell when they're on to us we'll
feel that and we think oh maybe we
should leave but if we actually just
keep playing it might take them an hour
or another two hours to actually get the
go-ahead to back off a car counter so in
general the approach that me and my team
make usually is just to keep playing
until we get backed off so in which case
the vast majority of the time we'll get
a back off but it depends on the casino
sometimes I could last the shortest was
about 12 minutes and this was pre
YouTube videos but someone just thought
he looks like a card counter called
surveillance and then surveillance were
watching me from the very first hand
played and very quickly figured out that
I was counting but then I've had nine
hours in the casino in a shift and gone
back the next day and sometimes just
weeks at one casino before they actually
caught me so it really varies but we
play aggressively until the back off
usually how how do you choose the
particular casino that you're going to
go and take on because if it was a
Hollywood movie it would be because of a
vendetta that the guy's current ex-wife
is now dating the owner of that
particular Casino I guess it's probably
more strategic than that yeah a little
bit although there is a a small element
of Revenge sometimes in that I think a
lot of Casino staff think that if they
give the card counter a really hard time
and back them off and make it really
hard for them to get their money at the
cage and send their photo everywhere and
and just be really aggressive that the C
counter will go that was horrible I'll
tell all my card counter friends how bad
this casino was and we'll all avoid it
but the exact opposite will happen the
card count will tell the people I had
this really hard time at this casino and
then the C they're telling will be like
all right where is it I want to because
there's a sense of that's not right so
might as well prioritize that casino but
in general we'll play any casino that
offers a good blackjack game not all
Blackjack is created equally there's
different subtle rule changes that can
affect how much we'd win there's certain
elements of the game which might affect
how risky it is or how long we'd have to
play to guarantee that we're going to be
up so but in general if if there's a
with a good blackjack game will play it
okay Vegas is Vegas a genuine Hot Spot
you've mentioned it before but surely
they've got to be [__] hot when it comes
to security they've probably got the
best surveillance departments in the
world but also they're the most used to
card counters so the backoffs tend to be
tends to be quite chill I say as I'm
thinking of lawsuits that that are going
on against Vegas casinos but in general
they tend to be pretty tend to be pretty
chill but they are very very fast so we
play Vegas mainly because we really like
it and it's so Casino dense there all
these casinos that you just have this
what feels like unlimited options and
because it's so fast moving it feels
like even when the shift changes it's
like a whole new casino so there is a
lot of opportunity in Vegas a lot of car
couns hate Vegas and they think it's
really bad and it might be compared to
other places but also Vegas has a
certain kind of weird charm to it that
just makes it a fun place to play maau
is that too dangerous go over and get
taken by the
CCP yeah I I've not I it was on my list
of places to try but I think I spoke to
a card C friend and and he said that
they don't have any shoe games I don't
know if that's true but nowadays it's
becoming more and more common that
there'll be this machine that is
constantly shuffling the cards so you
play out a hand or two they pick up the
cards put them back in the machine and
it constantly shuffles and those you
can't count because I mean there's
nothing to count when they're constantly
shuffling and I've heard that maau is
just ases that which is a shame because
I'd be well up for it yeah there's a
couple places on my list that countries
that I probably won't name but that I
want to go try but yeah I don't know if
macau's playable
is it fun or stressful like talk to me
about the felt sense of either being
part of a team and being a spotter or or
doing solo play like what's the actual
felt sense of it is it a
grind yeah it's it's a combination of
things it can be a grind for sure
especially on those seven hour Blackjack
sessions I I know I keep referencing the
last trip it's just because I just got
back but there was one time when I was
just so tired and wanted a break but I
hadn't been backed off so I just kept
going and I was sort of begging the
casino internally to back me off so I
could go take a break but you just don't
want to give up this opportunity because
who knows if the stars are going to
align there might have been a
surveillance person that's written you
off not from something you did and they
think ah he's not a cow counter so you
don't want to give that up and that can
be a real grind playing the same card
game because also the thing is is you're
not making decisions in the same way
that the average player is you know the
average player playing Blackjack will
get their 16 versus a 10 and they might
think oh should I hit this time or
should I not hit and they get to sort of
play the game but all wor really doing
is we've internalized like a decision
tree that we've memorized and that that
changes depending on the count but we've
just got a preset memorized formula and
we're just pressing go on that formula
so we're not really making any decisions
it's very much like an automatic process
so that can be a bit tedious in general
though it's more of a thrill than it is
anything else you are still getting the
same I guess dopamine hit from gambling
except you know that you have an
advantage which is a very satisfying
satisfying thing and the whole thing it
does feel like a massive Adventure but
it's all it's like such a weird
combination of emotions it's super
stressful it can be really stressful
especially some of the times when we've
been backed off and they'll not pay out
our money or be incredibly aggressive
but the overall experience is incredibly
rewarding and as soon as I come back to
the UK I'm sort of thankful that I get a
bit of a break but then I'm sort of
itching to play again because of that
combination of things yeah what what are
some of the worst backoffs that you've
had in your career yeah the worst one I
had was I think oh there's a there's
been a couple of contenders recently but
I think Chip Casino in Washington state
people have people have asked me why
aren't you calling these places out so
there you go there's the exact name CH
Casino in Washington state gave me the
worst I think I was playing there and in
essence I've been backed off from their
sister property well they they sort of
forcibly ided me and I'd left and they
chased me out the casino so I was
playing it tup and it just hit this
point where a guy came over to me tapped
me on the shoulder and I turned around
and I knew it was a back off and I did
the thing that you probably shouldn't
do I acknowledged that the guy you know
was backing me off I just said okay I
get it no more Blackjack because I was
trying to alleviate any hostility before
it even happened but he said no no no I
just want to see your ID I said well I
don't really I'm I'm happy just to go I
I'm I'm good I just want to cash out and
leave it's important for me to not here
that a lot of people think that when
you're in a casino you need to show ID
or you need to have an ID now yeah if
you're going up to the table and you sit
down and they ask you for an ID and you
don't show it they have the right to not
let you play or they could ID you with
the door and turn you away if you don't
have an ID but if you've played
blackjack have your chips you then have
the legal right to cash them out and you
don't need to show an ID couple of
asteres if it's over 10 grand changes
things but you don't need to show ID
however casinos will often try and force
you to show ID so that they can get your
name upload it to their little system
write their little report maybe send it
to other casinos and as a car c count
you really don't want to give your ID
for the most part and presumably using
fake ID would then be a federal crime
yeah exactly yeah I'm not sure if
there's maybe some weird loopholes in
that but it's not something that me or
anyone on my team has ever experimented
with but yeah there's a good phrase I
think it's from Molly's game if you've
seen that movie but I think it's uh the
phrase is don't break the law when
you're breaking the law which is
something I always think about when when
card counting what we're doing is not
illegal just it feels like a crime but
it's not quite a crime so don't mix in a
crime like fake
ID yeah okay so this guy right yeah so
he comes over and he's just immediately
he's got this such this sort of I don't
even know how to describe it but this
this kind of Macho Alpha energy where
he's decided that he's getting my ID and
he's immediately just demanding it and
I'm declining it and then he just
escalates and he goes I'm not gonna play
games with it you either show me ID or
you get out I'm like well I just want to
leave grab your chips get out you can't
even cash them out which was the first
time I'd been in that situation where
the casino was denying me a cash out and
I'd been advised by card cter friends
that if I just Stand My Ground
eventually they will cash me out so
that's what I decided to do and I just
wouldn't leave this casino until they
cash me out and they immediately brought
over extra security a gaming commission
person who once again the gaming
commissioner should be impartial but
when it's a I mean there's a whole host
of other politics regarding that stuff
often the gaming commission isn't
impartial they're a bit biased towards
the Casino so there's the gaming
commissioner multiple security people
other Casino staff and this whole big
argument breaks out well I'm just
basically shouting that I just want my
chips all of this is I got on hidden
camera and they just won't do it they
say that they're going to call the
police they call the police and then
they all start to kind of leave me alone
at this point they start to just sort of
leave maybe except one guy and I'm a bit
concerned because this casino is in sort
of tribal land so it's on an Indian
Reservation so the law regarding Indian
reservations is a little bit different
regarding the rest of us law they have
like tribal sovereignty so they can have
their own laws that are a bit
independent so in a they can have tribal
court and obviously the casino is
bringing in all the revenue so in a way
the casino is funding these things maybe
not directly and the whole thing is just
a little bit a little bit different to
what I'm used to and that goes with the
police force too I thought the police
were essentially paid for by the casino
and whether or not that's true or not
that's kind of how I was reading the
situation the time so I was a bit
worried that the police would
immediately side with the casino and I
might be in a very bad situation so I
started slowly walking towards the door
not wanting to leave but at least if the
police came in then I could say I was
just leaving if they came with really
aggressive energy and as I'm getting to
the door the police arrive and they
immediately tell me to sit down ask me
what's going on and they asked my ID I
gave it over I wasn't really familiar
with the with the laws regarding when a
police officer can have your ID but I
thought they're suspecting me of a CR
which they weren't so it was a weird
thing but I gave over the ID we had this
whole thing and they in the end just
escorted me to the cash desk and got me
got my chips cashed out and they may
have given over my ID or not they said
they wouldn't but you never know but I
was actually really relieved that the
police sided with me I've had other
situations where the police have just
taken an a media no we we don't want you
here we don't want to help you side and
also gaming Commissioners that were
totally useless so but that was a kind
of a scary situation because of just how
aggressive the tone was and how many
people there were and how early it was
in my card counting journey and the fact
police were called so that was pretty
bad one but there's been so many that
are quite
similar yeah that especially if you're
tired and stressed and have been playing
for a long time keeping your cool as
you're being pushed away from a game
that you know is taking every other
person sat in this casino's money and
the fact that you have manage to spend
enough time to be able to learn a
process that gives you a what's the edge
50 what is it oh it's like one or 2%
it's like tiny itend it's really really
small funny you should say that though
because there's been two instances that
that really banked this up one time also
in Washington there was a guy that was
at my table so drunk he couldn't stack
the chips up properly and he was just
playing and just pushing the chips in a
pile no idea what he's doing losing hand
after hand after hand he was tipping the
dealer every hand something like 25
bucks and I just made eye contact with
the dealer and just sort of said is he
okay and the dealer totally just just
fobbed it off I like he's fine and then
20 minutes later that I get backed off
and I just thought you're letting this
person play that's clearly not in of
sound mind to play because it benefits
the casino whereas here I am being
kicked out for playing the game honestly
and another thing that happened when I
was in Vegas that isn't in a video yet
but I found out that there was a player
at my table and she was I think a 77
year old woman she'd been playing for
over 24 hours and she hadn't eaten or
slept and I sort of spoke to a couple of
members of of Staff about this I asked
mentioned it to a dealer I was like hey
she's been playing for you know this
long do you think you know like is there
something and the dealer laughed it off
I then spoke to a Pit Boss same kind of
thing at this point I knew that they
were running my game down I knew that I
was my time was limited so making a bit
of a spectacle wasn't really going to
cost anything and each person I spoke to
in essence was just totally fine with
this woman continuing to play and it's
just one of those things where I get
that everybody makes their own decisions
and has a right to do what they want and
I guess and I get that there's high-ups
in the casino that are setting these
policies about how they handle people
that have gambling problems but I also
was just left thinking isn't there
like anybody that's just sort of going
to go hey maybe take maybe take a
10-minute break maybe go have a sandwich
and just see just no like what point is
it just a human decency thing that
wasn't you are if if you are going to
casinos in the hopes of finding some
ethical decency I fear that you may be
looking in the place I know but still
casinos are made up of individual people
right when I look at them as
institutions I'm like yeah they're
horrible but they're still like
perfectly nice members of staff that
I've met in casinos yet this kind of
thing happens I mean recently there was
a I've just been told I was told by uh
someone that works in Casino industry
that a casino in Vegas is being sued or
being sued because somebody died at the
blackjack table and the the dealer kept
dealing the cards oh my God they had a
heart attack and they only realized when
the when the dealer switched and it was
a new dealer and this dealer was like
are you okay oh my god
dude it's wild I I was watching a story
it might have been a sunny V2 video
about this Chinese millionaire
multi-millionaire who lost in the space
of 18 months two years in Vegas was
flying back and forth and lost nearly
200 million at the same casino and yeah
was just propped up on a cocktail of all
sorts of stuff for the entirety of the
time he was I think he was playing
Blackjack to yeah it's wild like surely
the whole because I've seen what
Blackjack can be when it's fun and when
people are having a good time and there
are rare occasions where the whole table
is losing money as as is going to be the
case but everyone's still having a good
time and I'm like oh yeah it can exist
in this space which isn't like
completely depressing but so much of the
time there's no there's just it just
seems like there's no actual care of the
people play which really like how do you
deal with these sessions where you end
up being lots of money down and and how
how much can that get and how much can
that get across a team as well in a day
yeah we can lose tens and tens and tens
of thousands I think the biggest loss
that we have on record for our team in
one session and I think that was
probably like three or four hours was
one of my teammates called syntax he
played and lost 42k which is I mean he
posts we have like a little results
group chat and he Post in the group chat
this is a result and we all just
immediately feel it because it's it's so
much money no matter what the context is
outside of that no matter what you were
up at one point or anything it's still
42 Grand your brain automatically thinks
how many years rent is that or how many
it's just it's crazy so the times that
are the worst are when you're losing not
necessarily a huge amount but it's
repeatedly session after session after
session and you're on what seems like a
NeverEnding losing streak the first time
we played in Vegas in in 2020 we won I
think it was something like 97k in two
or three days which is the best thing
ever and then in the next couple days we
proceeded to lose 110 from that point
and just the way down Chris it's not fun
because each time you're thinking
someone's gonna have a win and then but
maybe there's a couple K someone wins
but then someone else loses 10 and
you're just like it has to stop and I
remember I had a session where I lost
30k on that down swing and I just went
into the into the restroom and just sort
of had to splash water on my face and
just try and compose myself and then I
went out and there was a bunch of
security guards waiting for me which was
lovely oh fantastic just what you need
it it can be really tough and I think it
it sort of takes more than it gives in
away I think you have to have the it's a
certain kind of person to be a card
counter just for like I don't mean who's
capable of it I think a lot of people
could learn it but the actual lifestyle
and having to go through those losses
and having to lose that money and not
change what you're doing you can't chase
your losses you just have to keep
playing like a machine there's times I
really want to leave because I'm down a
lot of money and I just want to break
but the Count's still high so you've
just got to keep going and you're buying
in you're losing you're buying in you're
losing and the dealer keeps getting
blackjacks and you're just like this is
what are the odds of this but you still
have to just keep going and that those
are some of the hardest times that's the
reason why playtime is so important then
because you need to be able to
accumulate knowing that given a long
enough amount of time you're going to be
one or 2% up which means across infinite
time you would win and therefore if you
have too short of a bunch of sessions
just straight up variance allows to chip
into you and chip into you and chip into
you and despite playing the right way
even on hot tables you can still lose or
it can just the count can just never get
to where you need it to be and you will
continue to walk away with means that's
why it needs to increase you need to
have that longer time for sure yeah it's
all about getting those hours in quality
games can also you know affect the
amount of hours you need but in general
yeah it's just all about getting those
hours in because in the short term you
are just flipping coins and hoping for
the best all right so what about good
games what have been some of the best
ones that you've been a part of oh if I
if I mentioned them they might make them
worse yeah I'd be actually really
cautious about saying place has got the
best black chat game because I genuinely
no no like what days what days have you
or what sessions have you done
where oh right which are the days where
it's just like we can't lose yes yeah I
think some of some of the team sessions
which have ended in when we've been
doing team play and they've just been
you know anything honestly anything
above like 30k win feels like fantastic
no matter what Stakes we're playing at
so yeah 30k 40K wins are always really
satisfying I yeah yeah there's there's
just been sessions I think I had a 19k
session in my one of my more recent
trips which maybe doesn't sound like a
lot in the scheme of what we've lost at
times but there's something just so
satisfying about even just winning 10
grand 20 grand and knowing that you're
going to post that in the chat and
everyone's going to see that that's
incredibly satisfying so yeah we more
look at it in trips as opposed to days
but we we've had some very very
successful trips that have just been
really really big wins in the six figure
range and that that for being a couple
week work is is pretty good even if you
are splitting it between a lot of people
yeah
how you've mentioned $10,000 anything
above that it's difficult to get cashed
out without giving your ID in so do you
purposefully know when you're at about
10 grand and then stop yeah that is a
strategy so so just I'll have to make
this super clear in case it sounds like
I'm promoting illegal conduct if you
have bought in or have got essentially
10K worth of chips generally then
there's a currency transaction report
that the casino has to fill in and if
you are Cashing Out 5K at one cage and
then going to a different cage and
Cashing Out 5K you could Dodge that that
report because they might not realize
you have the 10K that is actually a
crime called structuring so if we hit
that 10K Mark for whatever reason then
we have a hard rule where you just go
and cash it out and you give over the ID
now maybe you don't necessarily need to
cash it out there in then depending on
the circumstances but in general you're
still going to have to show show the ID
so yeah if you're playing a session
provided you're not Midway through a
shoe because you never want to leave
when the count is high that would be
very very bad because you're throwing
away money yeah if you're up 9k in a
session and it's the end of the shoe and
you realize oh if I win one onek more
I'm gonna have to hand over my ID it's
probably not going to be worth giving
over the ID so then we'll just leave but
we'll never actually physically Dodge
those checks if we legally have to do
them all right and how the [__] do you
get six figures back into the UK yeah
this is weirdly a question that no one
really asks which is like no one really
asks about the actual cash management
but yeah we have like so much cash we
have to move around airport security is
always annoy it's in cash right it's in
oh yeah it's Cas wedes of hello sir
where is this $150,000 come from it
literally is that so we just we each
have just money belts filled with money
and we have to just go through so I mean
when you go to the airport if you're
transferring more than 10 grand in US
currency you have to sort of declare it
so we just go through those checks and
you fill out a form you've got to fill
out the form again maybe when you get to
the get to the airport even the airport
staff don't often know what you have to
do and we have to really insist no no no
we have to speak to a border patrol
officer before we go through airport
security or we're in a real bad spot and
they're oh okay well um I guess if you
go downstairs and knock on the door so
there's weird things like that but yeah
we just take it and sometimes there just
these awkward conversations that we have
to have do you tell them where it's come
from well yeah I mean I mean the the
origin is honestly gambling it's just it
doesn't sound very probable it and it it
sounds like the perfect it's like the
kind of thing you would do if you were
trying to launder money or move
money so it's like the the honest answer
is not super reassuring so sometimes I
go through my phone and I'll be like
look here's all these photos of us in
the casinos and here's this here's me
being chased out by airport by the
casino security exactly yeah but there's
nothing illegal about taking cash around
the thing that we're really worried
about or I'm concerned about is law in
the UK US called civil forfeiture have
you ever come across these YouTube
videos Chris where there's people that
it's absolutely it's insane so someone
will get pulled over by a cop for
whatever reason and then the cop might
go oh JY Firearms or currency in the car
and the person might go well actually
yeah I've got some I happen to have my
life savings this one guy does Didn't
Trust Banks he had like I can't remember
how much it was but I think it was in
maybe the low six figures so we had a
significant amount of money and then the
police officer has the legal right to
just seize that money if they're not
convinced of where it's come from and
that it's legally held they can just
take it and have it and as far as I'm
aware it can be really difficult to get
that money back that money can be used
within the police force or something
weird but just one of these laws that
that seems so backwards where they can
just take the money from you and that's
it you'll get a little receipt but
getting it back is a whole other thing
so I've often worried about oh What if I
get pulled over because you don't want
to lie to a cop either you don't want to
say oh I have no Curren you're right
it's a to you're in a different set of
problems then but yeah there that's the
thing I worry about the most is just
being it's honestly just police in the
US regarding regarding the cash of
course being mugged and stuff is still a
concern in fact just on the I was
playing in the we were playing in the
Bahamas recently I was in the Bahamas
were you I went to so I went I went to
the Bahamas for two days and before I
went I was at a wedding in Northfolk
Virginia and this is when we' confirmed
this episode and I'm watching some of
your Vlogs and stuff and I'm like uh
talking to this guy and this guy was a
part of the Navy this wedding right he
was saying dude do you gamble like no no
I know a guy that does actually uh well
I'm about to speak to a guy that does
and he says dude the SLS and Paradise
Island the two casinos that you've got
in the Bahamas he like their dealers uh
they haven't got a clue the airport the
um see no security aren't that tight and
blah blah blah so I remember thinking at
the time I might be able to tell
Stevenson he doesn't know about here but
it seems like you beaten me to the punch
yeah that's really funny I mean I wonder
if we were there at the same time but
yeah I was I was over there and we just
had a situation where we this is like a
weird tangent story but we were playing
at this casino and it was just me and
Irish that were at the casino and we
ended up leaving the casino together
normally we wouldn't be seen with each
other but we both got so lost in the
casino and didn't have like cell service
that we ended up just in the end walking
out and hoping that the cameras hadn't
seen us so we left this casino finally
find a bit of road we really we got so
lost in this massive building and a taxi
pulled up and we we got into the taxi
and the taxi started driving and then
the uh I was a little bit concerned that
it wasn't a real
taxi but I wasn't sure and there had
been another taxi driver that told me
that the taxis in Bahamas are chill so I
wasn't like super worried but then the
taxi driver started offering us like
prostitutes and drugs and I was like ah
maybe this guy isn't a legit taxi driver
so we're driving and he said oh you're
going to need to give us directions
because I don't have a saav or GPS bit
of a weird flag for a taxi driver but
okay and we've got between us I don't
know how much it was but 50 60k
something like a lot of money and then
the taxi guy says by the way I'm just
going to need to stop off at the strip
club to pick up some food that I've
ordered
at like this is 4 in the morning or
whatever and it just sounded like the
most sketchy thing we're about to be
mugged cover story that's kind of how I
felt right and i i s we were like no no
no we'd rather you just take us home and
he goes it's on the way this guy doesn't
even know he doesn't know the address so
it's on the way and he says no no no I
have to do I've already I've already
picked it up and I messaged Irish saying
are you a bit worried that we're about
to get mugged you know long story short
is we actually go through these quite
unsafe
area of the Bahamas and Bahamas is like
super chill but there's obviously going
to be crime areas in every place that
you go and uh and then he pulls up
outside this building which didn't look
like a strip club and there's some like
Heavies outside the building and he gets
out and he goes inside which made me
feel a bit better because he left us
alone but I'd like been shoving my my
cash down at my trousers to sort of just
hide it because I was like being mugged
is one thing but being mugged and robbed
of like 50 60k is another and and then a
guy one of the heavy said don't worry
I'm a cop and this guy was stoned out of
his mind and flashed this badge and he
goes I've known this guy for years well
if you've known the guy that's you know
propositionally like trying to sell
prostitutes and drugs I don't know if I
feel like this is a great character
reference but the whole thing in the end
was just like a false alarm and the guy
got back in with his takeout and the
strip club from the strip club which
okay and drove us to rbnb but it was
just like the first half of that story
was the story where you get mugged and
then we luckily didn't have the second
half but it's moments like that where
you get yourself these situations where
you're in some Street you don't know and
you've got a lot of cash on you and then
you don't really know what to do there's
been times in the in the US where I've
looked up afterwards where I've been and
gone oh this is an incredibly High area
place that I was staying should not
should not have been there yeah on the
map this is the red part for crime and
yeah Wonder Grand down my pants yeah we
like we have to load of cash in the car
once in in um West Philadelphia and uh
that was dumb but we just left a
backpack in the car we forgot about with
cash and I just thought the next day
that it was going to be gone but it was
it was there as was a ticket on the car
but I'll take that any day you can use
the cash in the backpack to pay the
ticket that's on the car exactly right
yeah unfortunately that wasn't a team
expense I had to pay that but never mind
shame um so you must be having to do
more elaborate disguises and covers
given the fact that you've got a YouTube
channel with half a million people on it
it's not going to be any easier after
you've done this episode with me either
so I guess you're
uh the detailing of your experiences and
the difficulty of your experiences are
inversely correlated to each other yeah
it's weird it's like I'm My Own Worst
Enemy because as my YouTube channel goes
up then my car count gets harder so it's
like when when I started the series I
obviously knew that this could happen
but I the way I looked at it was well
either the series kind of simmers and it
doesn't really do any harm in which case
I'm card counting and it's fine or it
does really well in which case it's like
a luxury problem which is sort of where
I'm at right now but yeah I've had to go
all in on disguises so for the previous
trip I just did which isn't on YouTube
yet I we designed these different looks
you know using beard dye and changing my
beard and getting a goatee and fake
tattoos that were like the ones that
they use in movies so they look quite
real and I even went to a place called
fangs FX which make sort of fake teeth
and change how your jaw sits for actors
in movies and I didn't get fake teeth in
the end but I got like these jaw fillers
that just would push out the side of my
face and an upper bit of my face that
changed sort of how my face looked so we
were just doing everything that I could
pulling out all the stops and it really
worked as well I mean I got backed off
and I got caught eventually people find
out who I was it because you're stepen
Bridges though well yeah exactly it only
takes one person in surveillance to be
like wait a second guy and then and
that's it but it it absolutely brought
me so much more time and yeah it got me
way more time so it was really really
helpful because I was keeping track of
different looks in different Casino
chains so I'd know okay this casino
chain I'm still clean with this look so
I'll just Hammer this casino chain until
I get backed off you know when I was
mentioning before how I had this set
seven hour session or whatever and I
just was praying they'd back me off it's
because I wanted to stop spraying my
goatee with dye every day when I got up
and having to like makeup wipe all the
such a nut getting dye in my mouth I was
just like please let me change this
disguise but I was keeping track of the
luckily I've got surveillance people
that will me information which is super
handy new I was going to say so you've
got this network of fans who work
actually in the casino world you also
probably have a even larger network of
enemies that work in the casino world
but um yeah you there's like a FBI Most
Wanted do not admit under any
circumstances known Advantage player
list uh so are there some places that
you're never going to be able to go back
to now like are there some are there
some chains that are just completely
boxed off for you yeah not necessarily
some chains because in a way it's not
like every person that works in all
these casinos knows who I am by look
right but all of the casino chains will
know who I am and there'll be a
description and a photo of me in their
database and there will be a case of if
you see this guy back him off or don't
let him play however if I go to a new
region in the US that I haven't been to
for ever then there's no it's not like
they're looking through this of like
known Advantage players for every single
person there's thousands of of people
that are unwanted players for whatever
reason so it has to be the first someone
has to actually spot me for the first
time and then that that's s goes to the
top of the list and then it can become a
bit of a problem but yeah this there
maybe some casinos where I've played
before and because I've done a YouTube
video there'll be extra maybe everyone
in the casino will have seen it because
hey we're in this in this video and
which case I probably would struggle at
going back to those but I don't think
there's a chain that I wouldn't be able
to play at apart from the UK there's no
Casino I could go in the UK
unfortunately in the UK you've got to
you've got to be a member to go in 99%
the casino so I get sto at the door of
course of course what are there any
other games I mean you know it's so
funny to think about you being a
professional gambler but you're not
you're a professional blackjack player
like it's not it's this yeah a whole
panoply of different games that you
could play in this Wizard of Oz Charlie
Chocolate Factory way to lose money and
you just play one like are you do do the
Blackjack Advantage players speak to
the I don't know what like the [__]
backarat Advantage players or the
roulette Advantage players uh yeah so
there's sort of this larger community of
Advantage players and the other forms of
Advantage player kept pretty lock and
key and it I basically only do card
counting part for for a few reasons but
the main one being is that I wouldn't
feel comfortable doing other kinds of
Advantage Play on YouTube card counting
is a thing that exists in basically
every Casino you could go and count
cards whereas other forms of Advantage
play tend to be very select loopholes
that might get patched so if I shine a
light on something that's possible in
one game in Louisiana then that would
get patched it wouldn't exist anymore so
there's a certain kind of degree of
stuff that I wouldn't really want to
tackle on YouTube so I just sort of stay
in this Lane and go really hard on this
L but there is like
a I'm not going to go as far as saying
any game could be beaten
but there's there's lots of different
ways that you can exploit various
different games that people have figured
out right and has it ever been the case
have you ever been in a casino and seen
some other Advantage player either
playing blackj or playing some other
game have have like multiple teams
crossed streams at some point yeah I
don't think I've ever really had a
situation where two teams with big
player spots that be absolute nightmare
at the same Casino that's never happened
but there's been loads of times where
there's been other card counters not
that there's loads of card counters but
I've sat down at a table before started
playing and then when I raise my bet
somebody else is raising their bet and
I'm like wait a second and then you're
watching how they play and you're
waiting for a hand like soft 18 you know
A7 because those are the kind of hands
that that non-car counters tend to play
wrong so you wait for hand like that and
then you see oh they played it correctly
this person's either really lucky with
their timing of their bets or they're a
card counter so if that happens the
etiquette is whoever got their last will
lead the
and it's just a non-verbal signal that's
Unwritten into the rules of the
degenerates of the Blackjack World
otherwise it's like synchronized
swimming right it just becomes really
obvious when I raise my bet to a ground
at the same time somebody else raises
their bet and then we both lower it at
the same time and Razer it it just looks
um it can look super obvious so that can
be an issue I've also had times multiple
times where I've sat down at a table and
someone's just gone Stephen good to see
you and just continue play
well even with that like if they know
that you're there to count
cards like they're just gonna follow
what you
do lot of time couns right okay okay so
I kind of be like do you like to play
alone that's this weird stifled
conversation yeah but no it can be funny
I kind of encourage you know if it's a
non-card counter I'll be like take
insurance when I take insurance which is
a move where you bet if the Dealer's got
Blackjack I'll just give like a little
tip or something or if they ask me a
question i' be like well I wouldn't but
there's also been times with the dealer
where you know if you're playing and the
dealer knows you're counting and then
let's say you're going to tip the dealer
you go oh do you want me to tip it to
you or do you want me to play it so you
can do this thing where you put the chip
in front of your your your own bet and
then they're gambling with you right so
there'll be a time like way yeah it's
just a common thing right that that that
that's done in um in casinos not count
it's just everybody so you'll be like oh
I might say do you want it or should I
bet it for you and they'll go what do
you think and if they know I'm C I go I
think you should definitely bet
it dude yeah I mean you must have had
the amount of dealers that you've spent
intimate time with hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of hours you know of time
with these dealers what's the experience
I guess that you're trying to remain
under the radar so maybe you don't speak
to them so much but like yeah what's
your Insight about the life of a typical
us Blackjack de
person I mean they vary as much as
regular people vary I think my
experience with all Casino staff is is a
complete mix bag there's been some
people and dealers that I just think oh
these people are so fun I want to be
friends with them in real life and then
there's other people that just aren't
very nice people so it's hard to sort of
really give a uh you to sort of try and
paint like a brush or kind of give an
idea of the typical person that works in
a casino because they vary so much I
mean certain security people can be a
bit power trippy at times a lot of Pit
Bosses can be quite power trippy but
some of them are really nice so it's
kind of hard to sort of give like the
archetype of a
dealer I think yeah I mean I've met a
lot of dealers that are really nice a
lot of dealers I've known I'm counting
and they haven't dobbed me in so those
people are nice and they have they could
have just made things really difficult
but then I've also gone and met dealers
that have gone and pointed me out when I
walked in the door after driving six
hours to get to the casino so yeah it's
a real mixture but yeah you can have
some really nice interesting chats and
actually the dealers being Tet is one of
the things that keeps me going on these
trips if it's not a team trip where
where I'm with the team you're away for
whatever it is two three weeks you don't
know anybody and you're just driving
around and your only human interaction
that you get is when you order a coffee
buy some food or playing at the
blackjack table and as an extrovert
being able to talk with the dealers is
one of the things which actually kept me
keeps me like sane on these trips so
yeah it's really nice when you get a
dealer that's up for having a bit of a
chat dude yeah yeah I didn't think about
that I didn't think about how you know
it sounds all romantic and fantastic and
cool and sexy but the reality of it is
remembering plus one D1 or zero in your
mind for eight
hours and then going to bed and then
getting up and doing it all over again
for a couple of weeks yeah I mean it can
be such a CH I mean I've done trips
where the amount of time spent driving
has basically one: one ratio the amount
of time playing so for every hour play
hour driving because there's so much
just got to go to this casino next
casino and you can you can it's not an
exaggeration to say you can drive 6
hours to the nearest casino because
you've had to leave the town where that
town with the five casinos have all
called each other and told them what you
look like so you burnt out that town
when you just got there you drive six
hours to get to the next place and you
walk in and someone in my case
recognizes me or maybe you just get a
quick back off and it's just those times
are just it's just brutal because you
get back in the car and you go all right
got to go drive another three or four
hours to the next place now and yeah so
it's way more way way more about
logistics than it is necessarily about
mathematics yeah for sure yeah the
actual math that you're doing isn't that
complicated it's just a bunch of
relatively simple components that get
quite tricky to do together but the math
gets about as complicated is you have to
look at the discard tray where the cards
are estimate how many cards are there to
the nearest half deck and then you
divide your count by that number that's
about as complicated as gets but even
that you're rounding down or whilst you
know trying to keep the conversation
going or not look like you're
concentrating a lot but yeah step
Bridges ladies and gentlemen Stephen I
love your YouTube channel every once you
go and check that out where else should
people go where do you want let me go on
the internet to to look at your stuff
thank you so much yeah I mean I am
mainly on YouTube but I'm also on
Instagram and x and threads kind of I
guess so yeah you can find me it's just
Steven Bridges wherever those places are
oh yeah Steven good luck with whatever
you're doing next cheers Chris if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe